bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant l'examen d'une
proposition de loi addites Amazon un
texte voté ici au Sénat fin juin alors
c'était ce visa modifier la loi du 10
août 1981 sur le prix unique du livre
une loi crée à l'époque pour préserver
les petits libraires avec la montée en
puissance aujourd'hui du commerce en
ligne il faut aujourd'hui adapter cette
loi et pour les auteurs UMP du texte la
livraison gratuite proposée par les
grandes enseignes représentent une
concurrence déloyale justement pour ces
petits libraires voilà tout de suite je
vous propose donc d'écouter l'examen de
cette proposition de loi l'ordre du jour
rappelle la discussion en deuxième
lecture de la proposition de loi adoptée
avec modification par l'Assemblée
nationale en deuxième lecture
tendance à encadrer les conditions de
vente à distance des livres et
habilitant le gouvernement à modifier
par ordonnance les dispositions du Code
de la propriété intellectuelle relatives
au contrats d'édition dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Aurélie
Filippetti ministre de la Culture et de
la Communication madame la ministre vous
avez la parole
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs
sénateurs et sénatrice nous arrivons ce
matin au terme du cheminement d'un texte
madame le rapporteur dont la valeur est
primordiale pour le Parlement comme pour
le gouvernement
pour la majorité comme pour l'opposition
les lois qui encadrent le secteur du
livre sont ordinairement le fruit d'un
large consensus
pour ne pas dire d'uneanimité au sein
des chambres et cette loi n'a pas dérogé
pour le moment à cette règle c'est le
signe de l'attachement profond de la
nation un sujet le livre l'économie du
livre qui participe depuis longtemps à
l'idée que la France se fait d'elle-même
de son histoire et de son avenir
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
mobilise deux leviers par lesquels les
pouvoirs publics
agissent en faveur du secteur du livre
la régulation économique d'une part et
le droit d'auteur
pour la régulation économique la
disposition que nous examinons viennent
compléter la loi du 10 août 81 pour
restaurer un équilibre entre les
différents acteurs que la loi de 80
avait pour objectif de consacrer pour
préserver la diversité éditoriale et
ainsi toute la chaîne du livre la loi
sur le prix unique du livre de 1981
avait déjà été adapté au livre numérique
en 2011 ici nous en complétons l'esprit
par des dispositifs importants afin de
préserver une juste concurrence
notamment dans un univers de vente à
distance à travers internet concernant
le droit d'auteur vous le savez la
proposition de loi habilite le
gouvernement allégétéré par ordonnance
c'est original comme dispositif mais
c'est la montre bien l'intérêt et
l'importance du sujet
nous allons donc pouvoir habilité par
l'ordonnant par ordonnance les
conséquences de l'accord tout à fait
majeur qui a été signé entre le Conseil
permanent des écrivains et le Syndicat
national de l'édition le 21 mars 2013 un
an c'est donc le temps qu'il a fallu
pour pouvoir faire entrer dans la loi
ces dispositions cet accord entre auteur
est éditeur est un accord absolument
essentiel fruit de plusieurs années
quatre années de discussion entre
auteurs et éditeurs il permet enfin
d'opérer et c'est très attendu et
notamment très attendu par les auteurs
opéré au sein du Code de la propriété
intellectuelle une modernisation des
dispositions relatives au contrat
d'édition qu'il n'avait pas pour
l'essentiel était revu depuis 1957 cela
va donc permettre aux acteurs du secteur
du livre d'aborder ensemble plus
sereinement et avec un grand souci de
protéger les auteurs la diffusion
numérique des livres cela elle va cette
loi va rendre les obligations des
éditeurs notamment au regard des
contrats d'édition plus conformes à la
réalité technique économique du 21e
siècle
cela va permettre pour les auteurs
d'aborder avec confiance la cession de
leurs droits en sachant que leurs
éditeurs de leur côté s'engageront à
travers ces contrats à avoir les
meilleures pratiques
l'article premier maintenant de la
proposition de loi encadre lui les
conditions de la vente à distance de
libre dans le cadre toujours de la loi
de 81 sur le prix unique du livre
il a été notifié à la loi a été notifiée
à la Commission européenne et aux autres
États membres de l'Union immédiatement
après la première lecture ici au Sénat
et alors que l'adhésion unanime du
Parlement au principe et à la lettre de
ce texte se dessinait cette notification
à la Commission européenne était vous le
savez une démarche tout à fait
importante pour la sécurité juridique du
texte elle était aussi l'occasion
d'engager un dialogue un dialogue
utile avec la Commission compte tenu du
regard toujours on va dire extrêmement
attentif avec laquelle la Commission a
constamment considéré les lois
nationales de régulation du prix du
livre et dans des plaises à certains tu
réfères chantre d'un libéralisme
échevelé la disposition et la loi 1981
faut-il le rappeler n'est pas une loi
anti-concurentielle c'est une loi qui
permet qu'une juste concurrence s'exerce
au sein du secteur du livre mais dans un
marcher évidemment réguler par la loi
sur le prix unique pré-unique qui est
fixé bien sûr par les éditeurs la
Commission européenne a pu ainsi faire
part de ses observations aux autorités
françaises
conformément à la procédure
d'information mise en place par la
directive de 1998 nos administrations
lui ont répondu le délai de statu quo
qui a nécessité donc nous prenions un
peu plus de temps en ce début d'année le
délai de statuto qui est prévu par la
directive de 98 afin que les États
membres préservent un délai raisonnable
avant d'adopter définitivement les
normes notifiées ce délai a expiré le 19
mai dernier nous pouvons donc envisager
maintenant et vous voyez que c'est tout
à fait rapide après l'expiration du
délai en toute sécurité au regard des
procédures d'information de la
Commission européenne l'adoption de la
proposition de loi dans des termes
conformes au texte issue de sa seconde
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et ce
sera aujourd'hui la position du
gouvernement la proposition de loi
notifiée complète la loi 1981 ne porte
aucune discrimination elle régule les
conditions de la vente de livres en cas
de livraison à domicile et vous savez à
quel point c'est important pour nos
libraires pour nos libraires
indépendants que nous puissions agir
agir ensemble pour les aider là encore à
trouver toute leur place dans un marché
du livre qui maintenant se développe
aussi à travers la vente à distance de
la même manière qu'en 1981 il fallait
créer les conditions d'une juste
concurrence en tracteur de la vente
physique il faut aujourd'hui s'assurer
des conditions d'une juste concurrence
entre acteurs de la vente à distance et
en tracteur de la vente à distance et de
la vente physique nous avons besoin de
nos libraires et nous partageons tous
cet objectif j'en suis heureuse je suis
heureuse de cette unanimité l'objectif
de préserver le tissu de librairie
indépendante sur tout le territoire
national
dans le cas des échanges que nous avons
eu avec la Commission européenne nous
avons pu clarifier la logique de la
proposition de loi nous en avions parlé
ici même lors du vote de l'amendement de
Madame la rapporteur en première lecture
la livraison gratuite au domicile du
lecteur constitue un avantage économique
qui est perçu comme tel par l'acheteur
et c'était bien la raison pour laquelle
il était important de lui associer un
prix fût-il minime ou symbolique de ce
fait cette pratique porte atteinte aux
équilibres et à l'esprit de la loi de
1981 enfin les autorités françaises ont
eu l'occasion d'expliquer pourquoi il
n'était pas pertinent de s'acheminer
vers une obligation de facturation des
frais de livraison à prix coûtant
parce que évidemment ça aurait favorisé
les gros acteurs ayant la possibilité de
négocier des tarifs très bas avec ceux
qui assurent la livraison et donc nous
avons défendu le fait que la rédaction
actuelle était la voie la plus adaptée à
l'objectif de diversité éditoriale dès
l'adoption de la proposition de loi si
elle a lieu aujourd'hui comme nous
l'espérons tous je souhaite poursuivre
le dialogue avec les commissaires
européens qui sont attentifs à ce texte
afin là encore de continuer à renforcer
les échanges entrepris à l'occasion de
la notification
vous savez aussi plus largement à quel
point j'attache beaucoup de prix
politique au projet de l'Union
européenne en matière culturelle nous
avons aujourd'hui un enjeu majeur c'est
d'adapter les outils de la politique
culturelle et de l'exception culturelle
à l'air du numérique c'était l'enjeu du
forum de Chaillot au début du mois
d'avril auquel j'avais invité outre les
parlementaires mais mes homologues de
l'Union européenne ainsi que de nombreux
artistes nous avons proposé à cette
occasion à la future Commission les
éléments d'une stratégie commune en
matière culturelle c'est également la
raison pour laquelle nous avons entamé
avec la ministre allemande de la culture
Monica grutters un travail que je pense
tout à fait déterminant pour la prise en
compte à l'échelon européen de nos
objectifs en matière de politique du
livre nous avons avec l'Allemagne une
très grande proximité de vue concernant
une stratégie conjointe pour protéger
encourager promouvoir le livre la
lecture à l'échelle européenne et ce
aussi bien sur support physique sur
support numérique nous avons aussi
conscience des enjeux qui se posent à
nous et des dangers et des menaces qui
pèsent sur la filière du livre dans nos
deux pays notre détermination est donc
totale pour continuer et ce projet de
cette proposition de de loi en est l'un
des exemples continuer à ainsi adapter
moderniser les outils de l'exception
culturelles à l'ère du numérique je veux
enfin remercier le Parlement pour la
patience qui a été la sienne au moment
de différer l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi alors même que
l'accord entre les deux chambres sur ces
termes avaient été obtenus sachez que ce
délai qui était nécessaire et qui était
obligatoire aura été profitable
puisqu'il permet de conforter notre
démarche et dans le même temps auteur et
éditeur attendent aussi de leur côté que
les termes de leur accord soient
transcrits dans le Code de la propriété
intellectuelle évidemment grâce on vote
conforme que j'espère aujourd'hui nous
pourrons leur garantir l'aboutissement
dans des délais extrêmement rapprochés
c'est à dire en septembre ou en octobre
de l'ensemble de la transposition de ce
contrat qu'ils ont signé avec les
éditeurs pour ces raisons madame la
présidente madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je souhaite
que le vote d'aujourd'hui puisse nous
permettre collectivement d'aboutir à ce
résultat je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame barissa qui arrive rapportant de
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
mes chers collègues devant l'Assemblée
nationale le 20 février dernier vous
avez qualifié madame la ministre la
présente proposition de loi d'essentiel
et de moderne rappelant son importance
pour la vitalité de la filière du livre
comme le consensus des auteurs éditeurs
et libraire en faveur un dispositif qui
les aidera à faire face aux enjeux de la
transition numérique de l'économie du
livre à cette occasion vous avez salué
l'équilibre trouvé entre la majorité et
l'opposition parlementaire à chaque
étape de la discussion je souhaite que
cette nouvelle lecture au Sénat n'y
fasse pas exception les étapes en effet
furent nombreuses avant ce jour chaque
assemblée apportant son expertise et sa
conviction dans l'élaboration d'une
mesure d'apparence modeste et pourtant
fort technique
pour mémoire l'article premier de la loi
du 10 août 81 relative au prix du livre
dispose que tout éditeur doit fixer pour
chaque ouvrage un prix de vente au
public tenu d'être respecté par
l'ensemble des détaillants toutefois le
commerçant est libre d'appliquer à ce
prix une remise maximale de 5 %. la
législation est en revanche moins
précise s'agissant de la facturation des
frais de livraison et ce flou laisse
libre cours à la systématisation par
certaines plateformes de commerce
électroniques du double avantage offert
aux clients qui bénéficient de la remise
légale de 5% et de la gratuité de la
livraison
un tel niveau de concurrence commerciale
freine pour les librairies toutes
velléités de développement d'une
activité en ligne économiquement viable
pire il contribue à l'érosion du
commerce physique de l'ivre désormais
plus coûteux et d'accès moins aisés
qu'un site de e-commerce délivrant
rapidement et gratuitement toutes
commandes à domicile afin de rétablir
autant que faire ce peu les conditions
de concurrence plus équitables entre les
acteurs du marché du livre nos collègues
députés auteurs de la présente
proposition de loi ont conçu un
dispositif prévoyant que seul le rabais
de 5% soit autorisé dans le cadre de la
vente en ligne à l'exclusion de la
gratuité des frais de port et mettant
ainsi sur un pied d'égalité commerce
physique et e-commerce au cours de sa
séance publique du 3 octobre dernier
l'Assemblée nationale a à l'initiative
du gouvernement intégralement renversé
la mesure
dans ce dispositif les livres commandés
en ligne dès lors qu'il n'était pas
retirés dans un commerce de vente au
détail ne pouvait bénéficier de la
ristourne légale les libraires se
voyaient donc offrir la possibilité de
proposer des livres moins chers en vente
physique en application du rabbé
autorisée de 5%. par ailleurs s'agissant
du seul e-commerce la concurrence entre
site ne pouvait plus porter que sur les
frais de livraison évitant ainsi une
atrophie des marges par l'application
quasi systématique de la ristourne de
5%. en revanche il n'était plus question
dans cette version de la proposition de
loi d'interdire la gratuité des frais de
port mais d'offrir la possibilité aux
plateformes de vente en ligne
d'appliquer sur ces frais dont elle fixe
elle-même le tarif une réduction
équivalent à 5% du prix du livre à qui
dans le cadre de la transaction
sur la base de ce texte voté à limité
par l'Assemblée nationale notre
commission de la culture a le 18
décembre dernier apporter une
contribution décisive à la mesure
proposée en y réintégrant la facturation
des frais de port à défaut les
plateformes de e-commerce les plus
puissantes auraient pu continuer à
offrir un service de livraison gratuite
asphyxiant une concurrence qui ne peut
appliquer de tels avantages nous avons
donc interdit la gratuité des frais de
port dès lors que la commande n'était
pas livrée en magasin puisqu'il nous
était juridiquement impossible de fixer
unilatéralement et autoritairement d'un
niveau plancher de frais de port ni
d'établir ses frais à leur coût de
revient
j'avais alors fait valoir que
l'interdiction de la gratuité de la
livraison aura un effet psychologique
sur le consommateur dont il convient de
ne pas méconnaître les conséquences
positives si modiques seront-elles sur
le rééquilibrage de l'environnement
concurrentiel du marché du livre en
ligne je crois toujours fermement à cet
argument au cours de sa séance publique
du 8 janvier dernier le Sénat à
l'unanimité adopter cette nouvelle
version la proposition de loi en y
ajoutant un double complément à
l'initiative de notre collègue Jacques
Legendre un délai de trois mois a été
fixé entre la promulgation du texte et
l'application effective de la mesure
afin de laisser aux opérateurs le temps
nécessaire aux adaptations logicielles
induites par la nouvelle législation à
l'initiative du gouvernement ce dernier
a été habilité à légiféré par ordonnance
afin d'intégrer dans le Code de la
propriété intellectuelle les
dispositions du contrat d'édition tels
que prévu par la corps signé en mars
2013 entre auteur et auditeur vous venez
de le rappeler madame la ministre pour
mémoire ce nouveau contrat modifie celui
en vigueur depuis 57 en édictant de
nouvelles règles dans trois domaines les
premières sont applicables à l'ensemble
des contrats d'édition qui doivent
désormais également couvrir l'édition
numérique des ouvrages est également
précisé l'obligation de reddition des
comptes qui pèse sur l'éditeur comme la
possibilité pour les parties de mettre
fin au contrat pour défaut d'activité
économique une deuxième série de règles
concerne l'exploitation imprimée et
traite de l'exploitation permanente de
la diffusion commerciale et des
procédures de résiliation enfin de
nouvelles règles ont été fixées pour
l'exploitation numérique notamment pour
ce qui concerne les modalités les
modalités de rémunération des auteurs
certes souvenez-vous madame la ministre
le choix de légiférer par ordonnance
était loin de recueillir notre
approbation toutefois l'urgence qui
existait à mettre en oeuvre rapidement
le nouveau contrat d'édition à la
demande notamment des éditeurs des
auteurs les plus précaires et l'absence
d'un véhicule législatif adapté dans des
délaisraisonnables on conduit nos
différents groupes à voter en faveur de
la proposition de loi ainsi modifier
c'est alors qui est apparu dans un qui
est apparu dans un calendrier quelque
peu précipités la nécessité de
transmettre le texte à la Commission
européenne dans le cadre de la procédure
d'information s'agissant des normes et
réglementations techniques et règles
relatives au service de la société de
l'information il a été procédé à cette
notification quelques jours après
l'adoption du texte par notre assemblée
cours et dès lors un délai de trois mois
avant l'adoption définitive de la
proposition de loi délai pouvant être
prolongée jusqu'à trois mois
supplémentaires si était émis un avis
circonstancié par la commission ou un
État membre au terme du premier délai le
nom respect de ce statu quo aurait
entraîné en application la jurisprudence
constante de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne l'inappliquabilité de
la mesure en conséquence et dès lors que
l'Assemblée nationale ne renonçait pas à
décaler la date d'examen de la
proposition de loi en seconde lecture
prévue le 20 février dernier celui-ci ne
pouvait aboutir à un vote conforme de la
version transmise par le Sénat malgré la
position prise en ce sens par sa
commission des affaires culturelles pour
sortir de cette ornière vous avez donc
Madame la Ministre soumis à nos
collègues députés un amendement de
suppression du délai de trois mois
introduit au Sénat à l'initiative de
notre collègue Jacques Legendre cette
suppression outre qu'elle ne dénatures
en rien le dispositif tient du fait que
les procédures européennes imposent hors
des d'ores et déjà un tel délai avant
que je texte ne soit définitivement
adopté dès que les opérateurs sont
invités à utiliser pour réaliser les
adaptations techniques nécessaires
surtout c'est un moment de suppression
voté par l'Assemblée nationale présentée
l'avantage de maintenir le texte en
navette conformément aux exigences de la
procédure engagée auprès de la
Commission européenne c'est de ce texte
ainsi modifié que nous sommes saisis
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
procédure de notification européenne
deux avis circoncis circonstanciés
relatives à la présence proposition de
loi ont été transmis à la France
entraînant immédiatement la prolongation
du délai légal de statu quo jusqu'au 19
mai
le premier avis émane de la Commission
européenne et porte sur quatre points
elle estime tout d'abord que le
dispositif prévu pourrait restreindre la
liberté de fournir des services pour les
détaillants de livres en ligne établis
dans d'autres États membres elle aimait
également des doutes quant à la
pertinence des mesures envisagées au
regard de l'objectif visé elle
s'interroge en outre sur les risques qui
sur les risques pour qui pourraient
faire porter que pourrait faire porter
les contraintes appliquées aux
détaillant en ligne sur les libraires
qui souhaiteraient se positionner sur le
marché du livre en sans disposer de
l'assise économique des plateformes
existantes enfin elle reproche aux
autorites françaises de ne pas lui avoir
fourni suffisamment d'éléments pour
justifier pour juger de la
proportionnalité du dispositif
le second avis circonstancié provient de
l’autriche qui oppose que pour les
bibliothèques scientifiques qui
commandent des monographies en nombre il
découlerait de la mesure française un
enrichissant un anhérissement notoire
des commandes de livres qui les
pénaliserait sensiblement parallèlement
ce sont ouvertes entre la Commission
européenne et le secrétariat général des
affaires européennes de délicates
négociation en vue d'adapter la mesure
aux remarques émises il en ressort que
si les autorités européennes semblent
prêtes à se laisser convaincre par le
dispositif de la proposition de loi
cette acceptation ne pourra se faire
qu'au prix d'une renonciation préalable
de la France à la mesure consistant à
interdire la gratuité des frais de port
que la Commission semble estimer
disproportionnée à défaut la France se
trouverait sous la menace d'un
contentieux et partant d'une
condamnation je l'ai réaffirmé devant la
commission lors de l'examen du texte la
semaine passée je vous le redis ce matin
en tant que rapporteur je ne puisse
souscrire un tel chantage les libraires
malmenés par la crise économique et par
la concurrence déloyale des plateformes
de vente en ligne attendent le vote de
ce texte depuis de nombreux mois nous ne
pouvons les décevoir on abandonnant un
élément majeur du dispositif que nous
avons voté le 8 janvier dernier dans une
belle unanimité ce texte constitue en
effet un élément fort du soutien public
au librairie dont vous n'aurez vous
n'ignorez rien mes chers collègues des
difficultés le marché du livre après
avoir longtemps et mieux que d'autres
industries culturelles résister à la
crise subit désormais une baisse de ses
ventes aggravée par la concurrence
déloyale que représente le véritable
dumping auquel ce livre quelques grands
enseignes pour ne pas dire une société
ultra-dominante de commerce
électroniques de livres
cette situation comme le fait que la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
ce matin représente le fruit d'une
construction partagée des deux chambres
majorité et oppositions confondues je
vous rappelle que l'Assemblée nationale
a adopté à l'unanimité la version
sénatoriale du dispositif on conduit la
commission de la culture à ce prononcer
en faveur d'un vote confort elle fut
également sensible au fait que les
textes que nous avons adoptés en matière
de taxe sur la valeur ajoutée sur le
livre et récemment sur la presse en
ligne allez également à l'encontre des
incantations à la commission sans que la
France n'ait été à ce jour condamné
enfin comme les autorités européennes
comment les autorités européennes
pourraient-elles justifier un
contentieux contre le dispositif
français qui protège les libraires sans
excès manifeste contre les détails en
ligne alors qu'elle demeure impuissante
face aux stratégies d'optimisation
fiscale développée par les Gafa Google
Amazon Facebook Apple etc
au-delà de la question fiscale le
résultat des dernières élections
européennes dans notre pays comme
ailleurs plaide pour une plus grande
fermeté des politiques nationales à
l'encontre d'une vision pas trop
libérale des règles de concurrence
défendues par la Commission européenne
au détriment trop souvent de nos
industries culturelles mes chers
collègues la commande la commission de
la culture c'est uneaniement prononcé en
faveur de ce texte dans sa version
transmise par l'Assemblée nationale je
vous propose donc de confirmer cette
position en adoptant la présence
proposition de loi sans modification
ainsi nous parviendrons au terme d'un
marathon législatif riche en péripéties
durant ces 6 mois parallèlement à la
présente initiative parlementaire la
politique du livre a été consolidée la
création d'un médiateur du livre
autorité indépendante chargée de
concilier les litiges relatifs au prix
du livre papier numérique répond à une
forte attente les acteurs du secteur en
outre plusieurs collectivités
territoriales soucieuses de conserver
leur libraire et librairie ont pris des
initiatives afin de les soutenir à cet
égard et en tant que c'est la crise de
Paris je salue les dispositions adoptées
par le Conseil de Paris le 17 juin
dernier visant à faciliter l'accès pour
les libraires indépendants aux appels
d'offres de la ville relatives au
manuels scolaires et aux livres jeunesse
pour conclure je me dois de rappeler à
ceux qui se méprendraient sur le sens de
notre initiative que la politique du
prix du livre dans sa genèse son
histoire et sa dynamique n'était pas mue
par l'unique souci de satisfaire les
libraires mais par la volonté de
consolider l'ensemble du marché du livre
dans ce domaine la concurrence par le
prix aboutirait en effet en peu de temps
un approuve un appauvirissement de
l'offre qui ne serait rien d'autre
qu'elle a pour un appauvrissement de la
pensée
quand il s'agit de culture la
concurrence par le prix constitue une
vraie mauvaise idée la proposition de
loi s'inscrit donc dans cette conviction
et cet objectif donner le cadre
réglementaire permettant au secteur du
livre qu'il s'agisse des librairies
physiques ou des pure players des grands
éditeurs ou des plus confidentiels des
jeunes auteurs aux auteurs confirmés de
continuer à nos étonner
l'unanimité mes chers collègues que je
vous demande sur l'adoption du texte
sans modification viendra renforcer
notre position je vous en remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur Jean-Jacques Pignard pour le
groupe
udi
UC
madame la Présidente de Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente de la Commission nous voici
donc comme vous l'avez rappelé parvenu
au terme d'un long processus législatif
qui sont surprises aboutira au vote
unanime de cette proposition de loi
originellement réduite à un article et
enrichit ensuite d'un second c'est vrai
qu'en commission certains ont pu
s'intégrer s'interroger sur la cohérence
de cet ensemble et pourtant le livre est
un tout il y a celui qui écrit il y a
celui qui le produit il y a celui qui le
vend il y a celui qui le lit et ce tout
doit s'adapter à la révolution numérique
qui renvoie dans un passé mythique la
plume d'oie le marbre de l'imprimeur ou
l'état du bouquiniste
alors si on jouait petit bras on dirait
que en rajoutant cet article 2 le
gouvernement utilise le seul véhicule
législatif dont il avait à sa
disposition pour aller vite mais si on
la joue grand seigneur on estimera avec
égal qu'il s'agit d'une ruse de la
raison
s'il peut donc être rationnel de lier
dans cette proposition de loi à la fois
la librairie en ligne et le contrat
d'édition on peut aussi peut-être
s'interroger sur le fait que les
réponses apportées à une première vue
sont contradictoire l'article premier
temps plutôt à restreindre la vente en
ligne au profit de la vente physique
tandis que l'article 2 en adaptant le
contrat d'édition à l'ère numérique dans
plutôt à favoriser la dématérialisation
des textes ce qui ne pourrait que
déprimer la vente physique des livres
mais en réalité je crois madame Nice
vous l'avez souligné au-delà de ces
contradictions apparentes il y a quelque
chose de plus unificateur qui politique
notre volonté de de défendre à travers
cette propulsion de loi très technique
une sorte d'exception française qui
respecte c'est l'article 1 la maillage
de tous ces libraires physiques sur le
territoire et puis l'article 2 sur la
réalité aussi de se défendre au plan
européen la spécificité de notre culture
je ne reviendrai évidemment pas aux
risques d'être dondans sur l'article 1
vous l'avez tous rappelé madame la
madame le rapporteur vient de le faire
cela aboutit effectivement non pas à
stigmatiser les uns par rapport aux
autres mais à rétablir des règles de
bonne concurrence
et concrètement à supprimer le droit de
faire une réduction de 5% du prix des
livres vendu pour les opérateurs en
ligne cet aménagement de la loi langue
aura cependant de la même de madame le
rapporteur dont on salue le travail un
effet me dit
sera-t-il durable la question vient
d'être évoquée contenue de
l'environnement européen dans lequel il
s'inscrit comme cela a été rappelé la
Commission a aimé de substantiel doute à
l'endroit du dispositif il reste un
drainerait la liberté de fournir des
services pour les détaillants de livres
en ligne d'autres États membres il ne
permettrait pas de remplir l'objectif
poursuivi il handicap après les
librairies souhaitant se positionner sur
le marché du livre en ligne il serait
disproportionné madame la ministre même
le rapporteur vient de nous apporter des
des propos plus rassurants et même
l'hypothèse que la France soit condamnée
existe malgré tout mais dans un esprit
de fronde bien hexagonale nous
soutiendrons cette proposition de loi en
l'état
et puis en amont de la vente en ligne il
y a bien sûr le contrat d'édition et
donc l'article 2 qui habite le
gouvernement a modifié par ordonnance le
Code de la propriété intellectuelle le
régissant il s'agit véritablement de
faire entrer le contradiction dans l'ère
numérique pour ce faire donc les
ordonnances sanctionneront sur le plan
législatif l'accord cadre conclut après
trois ans de négociation entre auteurs
et éditeurs le 21 mars 2013 sur le fond
nous ne pouvons ici au groupe centriste
que soutenir ce dispositif qui accueille
l'édition numérique dans le cadre légal
du contrat d'édition qui n'en fait pas
aujourd'hui mention qui sanctionne le
principe de l'unicité du contrat
d'édition tout en exigeant une partie
distincte pour le numérique c'était ce
qui était une exigence forte des auteurs
qui énoncent les obligations de
l'éditeur en contrepartie de la session
des droits numériques
nous soutenons aussi des autres
dispositions de l'accord sur
l'exploitation imprimée ou mixte qu'il a
encore clarifie et renforce les
obligations de l'éditeur vis-à-vis de
l'auteur quant à la forme les
ordonnances on vient de l'évoquer ce
n'est pas évidemment
un sujet qui passionne les
parlementaires puisque ça l'aide de leur
droit mais nous considérons aussi que
l'urgence nécessitait ce processus
ceci dit et je t'aimerai par là la mise
en perspective de ce texte impose en
relativité rentabiliser l'importance ce
que connaît aujourd'hui le livre tous
les secteurs économiques le vivent
également
face à la révolution numérique tous se
joue à l'échelon européen c'est ce qu'on
sait que très bien fait notre collègue
Catherine Morin de saillie dans son
rapport du 20 mars 2013 l'Union
européenne colonie du monde numérique
fait au nom de la commission des
affaires européennes du Sénat
par son caractère transversal le
numérique défile la vieille Europe il
renverse les modèles d'affaires il se
joue de l'impôt ils bouscule les règles
de droit
cet espace transfrontière est dominée
par une poignée d'acteurs privés non
européen qui deviennent rivaux des états
or notre pays et l'Europe demeure sur la
défensive en matière numérique
aujourd'hui par le biais de son agenda
numérique l'Union tant de dégager le
surplus de croissance que laisse espérer
le numérique pour l'économie européenne
mais cette approche par les usages
manque d'envergure politique qui se
soucient de savoir si l'Union européenne
sera consommatrice ou productrice sur le
marché unique européen
marché unique numérique qui s'inquiète
de la perte de souveraineté de l'Union
européenne sur ces données qui se
soucient de préserver
la diversité de la culture européenne EN
LIGNE bref il faut que nous prenions
tous en compte cet enjeu de civilisation
une prise de conscience qui s'impose à
l'échel européen car c'est le seul
échelon où on peut trouver une masse
critique pour peser dans le cyberespace
le Conseil européen d'octobre dernier
s'est timidement emparé de cette
problématique mais sans doute faut-il
être plus offensif il est temps que
l'Union dope une politique industrielle
et de la Recherche adaptée à l'économie
des données et de la cyber surveillance
en particulier pour mettre en oeuvre des
plateformes adaptées à ces exigences
culturelles il est temps d'adopter une
régulation offensive du numérique
garantissant le respect de nos valeurs
il faut enfin qu'au lendemain du net
mondial qui s'est déroulée à Sao Paulo
l'Europe se préoccupe de la gouvernance
mondiale du numérique et prépare
l'Internet du futur
notre groupe est à la pointe de ce
combat qui en particulier concerne le
gif aujourd'hui ainsi lors de l'examen
de la loi du 1er mars 2012 sur la
numérisation des œuvres indisponibles du
20e siècle nous avions déposé des
amendements visant à digner la TVA des
livres numériques sur ces délivre papier
c'était un geste mais la décision ne se
prenait pas ici alors madame la ministre
vous l'avez rappelé vous savez que ces
enjeux européens sont décisifs pour
notre culture et pour le livre en
particulier et nous vous soutiendrons
lorsque toujours lorsque vous ferez
entendre cette voie dans l'Union
européenne en tout cas aujourd'hui le
groupe centriste votera bien évidemment
cette proposition de loi en est un
merci monsieur le sénateur pour le
groupe CRC la parole est à Madame
Brigitte Gontier Morin
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues la loi sur le prix unique du
livre du 10 août 1981 a permis à notre
pays de maintenir un réseau dense de
librairie surtout le territoire et
d'assurer la diversité de la création
littéraire elle a permis de protéger les
librairies indépendantes menacées par la
concurrence des grandes surfaces qui
vendent des livres à moindre coût
reposant sur l'idée juste que la
concurrence par les prix déboucherait
sur un amoindrissement de l'offre
culturelle cette loi a créé le principe
d'un prix unique fixé par l'éditeur et
s'imposant à tous les détaillants le
maximum de rabais autorisé sur les
livres est ainsi fixé à 5% du prix
déterminé par l'éditeur cette
proposition de loi adoptée à l'unanimité
par le Sénat et l'ASSE nationale tant à
préserver la loi sur le prix unique du
livre en l'adaptant à la vente de livres
en ligne qui se développe comme on sait
très rapidement or le prix unique du
livre est aujourd'hui contourné et remis
en cause par les pratiques commerciales
des grandes multinationales du commerce
pratiquent qui relève d'une concurrence
déloyale ces grands groupes dont le plus
emblématique est Amazon offre en effet
les frais de port et accordent en plus
5% de réduction sur le prix des livres
relançant une concurrence par les prix
cette proposition de loi interdit donc
l'application de la remise commerciale
de 5% pour les livres commandés en ligne
et livrés à domicile ainsi que la
gratuité des frais de port
nous l'avons soutenu d'emblée et nous
allons continuer à le faire avec vous
car ce qui est en jeu c'est la
préservation de l'exception et de la
diversité culturelle ce texte protège la
culture limite les effets pervers
provoqués par les pratiques de vente en
ligne de livres contribuant à la
pérennité du réseau de librairie
indépendante sur notre territoire tel
déjà tellement fragilisé cela a été dit
et par la même donc la diversité
éditoriale s'agissant de l'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement en première
lecture qui autorise à modifier par
ordonnance des dispositions du Code de
la propriété intellectuelle relative au
contrat d'édition tels que prévu par
l'accord-cadre sur le contrat d'édition
du 21 mars 2013 je ne peux redire
comment comment première lecture que
nous ne partageons pas cette manière de
procéder la voix de l'ordonnance est une
procédure qui tente à déposséder le
Parlement de ses droits et à moindre
donc la démocratie pour autant nous
voterons cette proposition de loi enfin
nous saluons l'attitude de fermeté de
notre rapporteur et de la commission qui
a adopté une position unanime refusant
de céder aux menaces de la Commission
européenne cette dernière estime que
l'interdiction de la gratuité des frais
de portés par cette proposition de loi
serait disproportionnée et menace la
France de contentieux avec un risque de
condamnation ne nous laissons pas
impressionner et félicitons-nous au
contraire que la France soit porteuse
d'une décision courageuse et agissent au
niveau européen pour maintenir et
défendre le principe d'exception
culturelle elle l'a déjà fait sur la TVA
sur le livre et la presse en ligne
malgré les oppositions de Bruxelles ce
qui a permis à posteriori de faire
évoluer l'attitude de la commission
puisque aucune condamnation n'a été
prise
en parlant du livre et de l'Europe je
voudrais conclure mon intervention en
rappelant la nécessité d'une grande
réforme fiscale car les entreprises dont
nous parlons les plus payeurs établis
dans des paradis fiscaux ne s'acquitent
ni du paiement de la TVA ni ne sont
soumis au même taux d'imposition sur les
bénéfices en France selon la Fédération
française des télécommunications Google
Amazon Facebook et Apple
dégagerait environ 2,2 à 3 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires en France
mais ne verseraient chacune et en
moyenne que 4 millions d'euros par an au
titre de l'impôt sur les sociétés il est
donc
urgent d'avancer en ce sens et j'appelle
le gouvernement AEV pour qu'enfin
l'Europe se saisisse de cette question
du dumping social pour que ces
entreprises ne puissent plus poursuivre
leur stratégie d'accroissement des
profits au mépris du droit de la
fiscalité et bien sûr de la culture je
vous remercie mais puisque j'ai quelques
minutes
enfin de mon temps je voudrais parce que
avant le renouvellement c'est sans doute
le dernier moment où la commission des
affaires culturelles à intervenir en
séance publique donc je voudrais
adresser tous mes remerciements à Madame
la Présidente de la Commission pour la
manière dont à la conduit nos travaux et
je lui adresser toutes mes amitiés
merci madame la sénatrice monsieur fort
à saints s'étend absenté quelques
minutes je vous propose si vous en êtes
d'accord madame bouchou de vous donner
la parole pour le groupe écologique
ne courait pas ne courait pas
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente de commission madame la
ministre chers collègues le débat qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui est un petit peu
une exception dans ce que nous
connaissons dans cette Haute Assemblée
c'est-à-dire partir d'une proposition de
loi UMP
un dialogue fructuéri riche avec
l'exécutif la main à la pâte mise de
façon extrêmement habile par la
rapporteur du texte et finalement nous
avons réussi à montrer que lorsque les
intérêts de tous tendent vers l'intérêt
général nous pouvons avancer sur des
questions aussi importantes que la
question de la culture et la place des
libraires et des librairies la question
qui nous s'était posée à travers cette
PPL était simple voulons-nous la fin des
vrais librairies avec des vrais êtres
humains où voulons-nous uniquement vivre
dans le modèle virtuel d'une économie
avec un modèle qui se développe où nous
savons bien que l'entreprise qui a
développé ce modèle ne vise pas
uniquement le produit livre en réalité
le produit livre est un produit d'appel
pour une nouvelle économie ou les
contenants et les modes d'acheminement
ont en réalité et hélas beaucoup plus de
place que le contenu à savoir l'objet
livre
contenu des enjeux qui ont été fort
pertinemment décrit évidemment nous
soutenons cette PPL que nous voterons
avec enthousiasme même si nous devons
ajouter que selon nous les libraires
doivent encore travailler et ils le
savent à inventer l'évolution de leur
métier ils doivent aussi veiller à être
réactif concernant le mode d'achat en
ligne ça n'est pas une mode ça n'est pas
une lubie c'est une évolution très
profonde des pratiques et s'il n'y a pas
une riposte extrêmement structurée de la
profession des libraires inventive et on
va dire résolu notre notre PPL aussi
pertinente qu'elle soit ne sera qu'une
rustine sur une jambe de bois deuxième
point je n'y je ne l'évoque pas plus
longuement il y avait la question
des droits sur le numérique même si nous
ne sommes pas évidemment fanatiques de
nous retirer le travail qui est le nôtre
de faire les lois la méthode dans le cas
d'espèces de l'ordonnance c'était une
bonne solution pour résoudre un vrai
problème qui était encore en suspens
finalement lorsque l'on regarde ce texte
même si nous entendons les alertes au
plan européen je pense que nous devons
rappeler qu'il est question de culture
et que dans ce cas d'espèces la victoire
du marché puisque à l'origine l'Europe
était un grand marché dans le cas de la
culture l'optique uniquement business le
petit uniquement profit le petit
uniquement marché n'est pas une optique
pertinente et on pourrait même aller
plus loin que de dire que dans le cas
d'espèces les libraires allemands ont
justement l'impression que le modèle de
l'entreprise qui nous préoccupe est un
modèle éminemment cannibale est un
modèle éminemment anticoncurrentiel et
que peut-être par une ironie de
l'histoire dans un deuxième temps ce
sont peut-être ceux qui critiquent
aujourd'hui cette PPL qui invoqueront
des principes de respect de la
concurrence et qui peut-être sera liront
à notre point de vue dernier point on ne
peut pas parler de libraire de vrais
librairies sans parler de vrais livres
donc je pouvez recommander à tous un
ouvrage qui est vendu par le service
public via la Documentation française
que je recommande à tous et à chacun ça
s'appelle vers la fin des librairies
c'est écrit par Vincent Chabot un
sociologue qui a le mérite de porter ce
sujet de façon extrêmement claire et
pédagogique et qui montre je ne sais pas
si c'était son propos mais en tout cas
son travail académique le montre bien
que la PPL d'aujourd'hui à défaut d'être
une solution durable au problème qui
nous préoccupe est une solution
nécessaire à court terme le temps de
réinventer un nouveau modèle et je
dirais que le la chose qui qui me
préoccupe aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
question de la méthode et je ne vais pas
abuser de mon temps de parole mais si
nous avions pu trouver pour la question
de l'intermittence
autant de conscience du consensus et
d'habileté dans la discussion de tous
les partenaires que ce qui a été le cas
pour les libraires et les librairies et
bien peut-être la situation ne serait
pas aussi périlleuse aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas vous dire mon ami ministre
toute notre confiance et tout notre
soutien pour ce dossier difficile et
nous aimerions qu'il trouve à une fin
aussi satisfaisante que pour la question
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci madame la sénatrice je vais donc
donner la parole à Monsieur François
Fortin pour le groupe RDS
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y a des sujets
autour desquels l'ensemble des forces
politiques quelle que soit leur
sensibilité savent se rassembler c'est
très heureux c'est souvent le cas de la
culture et c'est plus particulièrement
le cas aujourd'hui de l'avenir du
secteur de livres et des librairies sur
lequel cette proposition de loi nous
invite à nous pencher s'il faut défendre
ce secteur qui doit tenir tête on doit
tenir tête à la Commission européenne
qui voudrait uniformiser notre façon de
voir le monde nous ferons avec unité
conviction la culture
occupe de tout temps une place
privilégiée dans notre pays et dans nos
politiques politiques publiques et cela
juste titre
l'harmonisation européenne
si elle est souhaitable dans de nombreux
domaines ne peut en aucun cas se faire
par le bas
et la préservation de la diversité
culturelle
qui est au fondement même de l'Europe
est un combat pour lequel la France fort
heureusement l'armée publie nous avons
d'autres alliés comme l'Allemagne car
récemment soutenu notre position sur le
taux de TVA réduit sur le livre
numérique nous avons également réussi
avec nos partenaires à imposer
d'exception culturelle dans des
négociations entre l'Union européenne et
les États-Unis sur l'Accord de
libre-échange mais il est sans cesse
nécessaire de rappeler eau et fort
l'importance de ces principes
aujourd'hui nous cherchons une réponse
aux pratiques proches de la concurrence
des loyale et qui relève en tout état de
cause d'un confinement d'un
contournement de notre droit et
notamment de l'esprit de la loi de 1981
sur le prix unique du livre par certains
acteurs de la vente en ligne ces
pratiques fragilisent la situation déjà
très délicate du nombre de nos
librairies indépendantes
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
deuxième lecture déposée à l'Assemblée
nationale par nos collègues du groupe du
MEP puis modifier dans un premier temps
par le gouvernement et ensuite par
Madame le remporter a été chaque fois
adopté à l'unanimité et je m'en réjouis
les modifications qui sont intervenus au
cours de son examen vise à préciser à
sécuriser à compléter l'article premier
ainsi une disposition s'attaquée à
l'origine à la gratuité dès l'original
gratuité des frais de livraison
pratiqués par certains grands acteurs de
la vente en ligne de livres nous sommes
passés en texte supprimant l'avantage
qui consistait à appliquer
systématiquement la remise légale de 5%
sur le prix du livre grâce à madame le
rapporteur nous examinons aujourd'hui un
texte qui interdit aux acteurs de la
vente en ligne d'appliquer ces
militairement ces deux avantages qui
associent la situation déjà
déséquilibrée de ce marché confère une
position plus que dominante dans le site
Internet il est inutile de citer puisque
tout le monde le connaît
car je parle des grands acteurs de la
vente en ligne de livres mais nous le
savons tous il y a avant tout un acteur
qui détient 70% des parts de ce marché
ce grand groupe américain dont les
visées ne sont nullement
philanthropiques a décidé d'utiliser
plutôt de contourner notre législation
pour en tirer un avantage commercial
incontestable mais faut-il rappeler que
ce géant du numérique comme la plupart
des autres groupes secteurs utilisent
sciemment l'ensemble des règles
nationales et internationales notamment
en matière fixe calle à des fins
d'optimisation le beau mot car la
frontière entre l'optimisation et la
fraude est souvent très poreuse
la commission des finances nous avons à
traiter souvent de ces problèmes
ce comportement choc à juste titre mais
ne tombons pas pour autant dans un excès
de stigmatisation qui consiste à voir
tous les grands groupes l'économie
numérique comme une menace l'un des
principaux enjeux de ces prochaines
années sera l'adaptation de notre
fiscalité numérique mais cela est un
autre débat
le numérique est aussi avant tout une
chance y compris en matière de
démocratisation culturelle il permet de
démultiplier l'accès à la culture les
sites de vente en ligne de livres sont
parfois le seul moyen pour certaines de
l'ont concitoyens d'avoir accès à
certaines ouvrages nos collègues qui
représentent les Français à l'étranger
l'ont rappelé en première lecture mais
cela aussi est vrai pour d'autres
catégories de population
par exemple les populations isolées les
zones rurales ou pour les personnes qui
en raison de leur état de santé ne
peuvent se déplacer pour pouvoir
commander sur internet une multitude de
références et les recevoir à domicile
est un véritable progrès
pour autant et c'est là tous l'intérêt
de cette position de loi il est vrai que
les grands acteurs du numérique
associent souvent les pratiques
commerciales agressives et une
utilisation contestable de la
législation afin de s'arranger à terme
une position dominante pour ne pas dire
monopolistique au détriment de tous
les membres de mon groupe du RDSE sont
extrêmement attachés à la préservation
d'un réseau dense de librairie sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui est l'une
des richesses de notre pays aujourd'hui
les libraires sont démunis face aux
pratiques ces acteurs de la vente en
ligne qui peuvent se permettre de vendre
des livres à perte en se rattrapant si
on peut dire sur d'autres secteurs ils
ne peuvent pas jouer à armes égales avec
les plateformes capables proposées des
millions de références immédiatement
disponibles avec une remise systématique
5% de la gratte et la gratuité des frais
de port cette proposition de loi apporte
une réponse certain suffisante et
peut-être incomplètes aux difficultés
délibres librairies indépendantes mais
elle constitue avant tout un signal fort
en direction de ces géants du numérique
100 fois ni loi pour qu'ils sachent
contourner impunément notre législation
dans le seul but de maximiser leur
profit c'est pourquoi convaincu que les
institutions européennes ne pourront que
nous donner raison l'ensemble des
membres de mon groupe soutiendra sans
hésitation cette proposition de loi et
qu'on va ma collègue a cité un ouvrage
moi je vous recommande
mais c'est un peu provocateur je le
reconnais
cette excellent ouvrage qui s'appelle
recouvrez-le de lumière
et qui a été écrit par un torero
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
à Madame colette-mélo pour le groupe UMP
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame le rapporteur madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi
issue du groupe UMP de l'Assemblée
nationale vise à compléter la loi du 10
août 1981 qui a permis la mise en place
du prix unique du livre loi adaptée aux
livres numériques en 2011
cette loi a été d'une grande utilité
pour assurer la protection de
l'industrie du livre secteur fragile
dont la pérennité dépend du régime
concurrentiel qui lui est imposé
en 1981 le risque provenait des livres à
rotation rapide ou best-sellers sur
lesquels les grandes surfaces autorisées
à pratiquer des rabais substantiels
nuisant ainsi au livre à rotation lente
qui avait besoin de plus de temps pour
trouver leur public ainsi qu'aux
librairie qui ne pouvait assurer des
rabais équivalents l'intervention du
législateur se justifiait donc par une
menace lourde qui pesait sur l'équilibre
économique de ce secteur d'activité
l'enjeu était aussi bien économique que
culturel puisque le prix unique
permettait de maintenir la diversité et
la richesse du paysage littéraire
plus de 30 ans après l'entrée en vigueur
de ce disposition législatives
l'industrie du livre est toujours un
secteur fragile mais le bilan est tout
de même très positif le prix unique a
permis au réseau des librairies de se
maintenir et de se moderniser sur
environ 25000 points de vente du livre
ont des nombres 3000 librairies
indépendantes ce réseau constitue
l'essentiel de la création littéraire
française et permet aux éditeurs de
maintenir des oeuvres durant de
nombreuses années dans leur catalogue
le marché du livre fait ainsi partie des
plus stables de tous les secteurs
culturels avec une importante assise
éditoriale environ 600 000 titres sont
disponibles et près de 60 000 titres
paraissent chaque année ainsi la loi de
1981 qui constituait une dérogation aux
règles habituelles de la concurrence a
en réalité permis de préserver celle-ci
en garantissant une grande diversité
d'acteurs tant au niveau de l'édition
que de la commercialisation
il la loi langue affiche un bilan
positif elle ne pouvait prévoir le
développement d'un nouveau mode de
commercialisation avec le développement
d'Internet et de la vente à distance le
développement du numérique représente
autant une opportunité qu'un danger pour
le secteur du livre en tant que support
de la vente à distance internet garantit
une large distribution du livre la
recherche l'achat a pris la livraison en
peu de jours assurent un soutien
précieux à ce secteur cependant la vente
en ligne est un marché dominé par un
nombre d'acteurs très restreint dont
amazon est le plus important puisqu'il
en détient 70% des parts
cette situation s'explique par les
offres très avantageuses proposées par
ce site qui cumulent les 5% de réduction
sur les ouvrages autorisés par la loi de
1980 avec la possibilité d'une livraison
gratuite par ailleurs amazon a pris ami
en place une stratégie d'optimisation
fiscale grâce à une installation au
Luxembourg qui lui permet de réduire au
maximum l'imposition sur ces bénéfices
français
les librairies indépendantes françaises
quant à elle doivent supporter les
charges de personnel les charges de
loyer les charges fiscales et
l'augmentation des frais de transport
l'industrie du livre se retrouve donc
face au même risque qu'en 1981 un risque
économique d'une part avec la suprématie
d'un seul acteur sur le marché un risque
culturel d'autre part avec une
production éditoriale qui pourrait
dépendre un jour d'un acteur en mesure
d'imposer ces conditions il s'agit bien
ici d'un enjeu à l'échelle nationale
pour lequel le législateur a un rôle
important à jouer
je salue d'ailleurs l'unanimité qui nous
réunit autour de cette proposition de
loi ainsi que l'ambiance de travail
constructive qui a permis d'améliorer le
texte celui-ci rend désormais impossible
la gratuité des frais de port toute
commande de Livres réalisées en ligne
devra obligatoirement faire l'objet
d'une facturation du service de
livraison à domicile certes c'est
interdiction de gratuité de livraison a
surtout une portée symbolique un effet
le but est principalement d'éviter le
message de la gratuité dans ce prévaut
aujourd'hui Amazon mais le coût de
livraison qu'il devra mentionner après
l'adoption de la loi sera nécessairement
très restreint et le consommateur aura
toujours tendance à s'orienter vers la
vente en ligne
nous librairies aurons besoin de
témoignages de soutien supplémentaire de
la part des pouvoirs publics il est
notamment regrettable qu'au niveau
européen aucune stratégie n'est plus
être adoptée face à la politique
d'optimisation fiscale d'Amazon et
autres plateformes cette situation doit
nous conforter dans l'esprit de
résistance m'a ancienné par notre
rapporteur dont je tiens à saluer
l'engagement sur ce texte le problème de
la position de la Commission européenne
est nouveau nous ne l'avions pas évoqué
en première lecture car le gouvernement
avait un effet omis de nous informer de
l'obligation de soumettre le texte à la
vie de la Commission européenne comme
toute réglementation technique relative
au service de la société de
l'information c'est d'ailleurs en
l'absence de cette précision que le
Sénat avait adopté l'un de nos
amendements présentés par le président
Jacques Legendre qui fixait un délai de
trois mois pour l'application de la
proposition de loi ce délai est devenu
inutile du fait de la procédure engagée
devant la commission
la réponse de la Commission européenne à
la notification montre malheureusement
sa défiance envers le dispositif que
nous nous apprêtons à voter en effet la
commission exige maintenant une
renégociation préalable à l'adoption du
texte car elle estime que la mise en
place de notre dispositif serait
disproportionnée au regard de l'objectif
visé et risquerait de restreindre la
liberté des détaillants de livres de
fournir à leur tour des services en
ligne sur la forme il est certainement
regrettable que le gouvernement est
temps tardé à s'enquérir de la vie de la
Commission européenne ce qui nous
obligerait à faire courir de nouveaux
délais si nous respections les
préconisations de la commission sur le
fond ces préconisations vont à
l'encontre des intérêts que nous
défendons puisque le respect de la
procédure souhaitée par la commission
entraînerait en retard dans
l'application d'une mesure de soutien
économique au secteur du livre voir son
annulation
or cette mesure est sollicitée par nos
libraires qui subissent actuellement une
concurrence qu'il faut bien reconnaître
comme des loyal notre groupe s'associera
donc aux messages de fermeté de notre
rapporteur je pense que nous ne devons
pas passer à côté de l'occasion de
rééquilibrer autant que faire ce peu les
rapports entre détaillants de livres et
plateformes en ligne en l'occurrence je
pense que la France doit jouer à nouveau
un rôle moteur pour répondre aux
nouveaux anges de rencontrer par le
secteur du livre comme elle a pu le
faire à l'adoptant en 1981 le prix
unique du livre à sa suite 11 pays de
l'Union européenne ont mis en place un
système identique
certes nous regrettons à l'occasion de
l'examen de ce texte que le gouvernement
est conduit ait été conduit à introduire
un cavalier sur les contrats d'édition
qu'il complétera par voie d'ordonnance
mais il faut pourtant admettre que
l'urgence nécessité ce processus
et cela ne nous détournera pas de
l'objectif que le groupe UMP s'était
fixé par le dépôt de cette proposition
de loi nous adopterons donc sans aucune
hésitation sa version modifiée et nous
nous réjouissons quelle rencontre de
nouveau
l'unanimité sur tous nos bancs je vous
remercie
merci madame la sénatrice dernier
orateur inscrit pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur Vincent et blé
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues
soucieux de permettre au libraire de
faire face à la concurrence des
plateformes en ligne et de maintenir un
réseau dense et diversifié de librairie
de qualité à l'instar de nos
prédécesseurs qui ont voté en 81 la
célèbre loi langue nous abordons ce
matin la seconde lecture du projet de
loi tendante à encadrer la vente à
distance des livres et habilitant
également le gouvernement à modifier par
ordonnance les dispositions du Code de
la propriété intellectuelle relative au
contrat d'édition
lors de mon propos en première lecture
je vous indiquais les souffrances du
réseau des 3000 libraires indépendants
de notre pays et les difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés
aujourd'hui à savoir la concurrence des
loyal en effet dont il souffre puisqu'il
paye leurs impôts en France
contrairement à une certaine plateforme
logistique de vente de livres en ligne
qui ne payent pas d'impôts à la hauteur
de son activité tout au moins cette
plateforme logistique ne paye pas non
plus de taxes sur les surfaces
commerciales puisqu'elles n'en est pas
une elle ne subit pas non plus les
contraintes financières liées à
l'augmentation des loyers dans les
coeurs de ville et elle bénéficie même
de subventions pour s'installer
difficulté délibrées également en raison
de l'impossibilité de systématiser la
ristourne de 5% puisque leur marge n'est
que de 0,6
problème de trésorerie avec l'exigence
d'avoir un stock important pour vendre
et répondre à la demande client stock si
coûteux en trésorerie enfin difficultés
de cession d'un fonds de commerce de
librairie dans le morose contexte actuel
sur l'éventualité de développer une
activité de vente en ligne l'échec de
mille et une librairies.com a révélé que
seuls les grosses librairies ont à ce
jour les moyens d'investir sur ce
secteur de marché et que dans tous les
cas ces ventes ne sont pas rentables et
guerres concurrentielles en effet
comment lutter face aux géant de
l'Internet qui superposent les frais de
port gratuit la ristourne des 5% et la
capacité à livrer en 48 heures maxi au
domicile du client à partir d'un
catalogue immense alors que dans le même
temps les libraires peinent à se
procurer des ouvrages en trois jours
face à ces constats au libraire n'étant
pas des champions internationaux de la
logistique notre intervention était
devenue nécessaire
cette proposition de loi se situe dans
un tel contexte et nous mesurons qu'elle
ne peut à elle seule bien sûr être une
solution elle s'inscrit dans une action
plus globale le gouvernement vous-même
madame la ministre de la Culture
agissait sur ce dossier depuis longtemps
déjà pour apporter des solutions au
libraire et tenter de les sauver à
nouveau le gouvernement agit en mettant
en place un contentieux fiscal pour 190
millions d'euros concernant la période
2006-2010 le gouvernement agit en
recherchant une imposition juste au
regard des règles de la fiscalité
nationale même si l'assujettissement
de ces entreprises à l'impôt sur les
sociétés s'avère extrêmement complexes
sauf à ce que l'OCDE réformes les normes
fiscales le gouvernement agit en
maintenant le taux de TVA réduit à 5,5
et non à 7 comme cela failli être le cas
à cela il faut ajouter les diverses
aides en faveur de la promotion de la
lecture du soutien à la création
littéraire du maintien sur le territoire
national d'un maillage conséquent de
librairie plus particulièrement le plan
librairie initié par vous-même madame la
ministre des montres l'intérêt du
gouvernement pour ce type de commerce
plan librairie pour objectif de
faciliter la transmission de celle-ci
d'aider celle qui rencontre des
difficultés de trésorerie et de façon
générale de mieux les soutenir je vous
rappelle également qu'ici même au Sénat
à l'initiative du gouvernement nous
avons récemment créé un médiateur du
livre et des agents de ministère
assermentés pour constater les
infractions à la législation sur le prix
du livre tel que d'ailleurs les
organisations professionnelles de la
librairie le demandait le groupe
socialiste tient ainsi féliciter notre
ministre pour l'ensemble de ses actions
et encourager tant le travail à
l'encourager pardon tant le travail qui
reste à faire est importante aujourd'hui
nous le savons notre réseau de librairie
est menacé et par la même ce sont plus
de 30 000 emplois qui le sont
ce texte veut être une pierre à
l'édifice à l'initiative de
parlementaire Seine-et-Marnais amendé
par le gouvernement lors de sa
présentation à l'Assemblée en octobre
dernier il permet désormais de limiter
les avantages offerts aux clients des
plateformes de vente de livres en ligne
le travail de notre rapporteur isaakari
a d'ailleurs permis d'affiner le
dispositif adopté par nos collègues de
l'Assemblée en première lecture
puisqu'il était très difficile voire
impossible d'intervenir sur des
dispositions mettant en cause soit le
coût réel des frais de port soit sur
l'établissement d'un prix plancher le
rapporteur nous avait dès lors proposé
judicieusement d'interdire simplement la
livraison gratuite après l'adoption
première lecture de ce texte par notre
assemblée est apparu durant la navette
parlementaire la nécessité transmettre
notre texte de loi à la Commission
européenne conformément l'application de
la directive 98 34 qui prévoit une
procédure d'information s'agissant des
normes et réglement ations techniques et
des règles relatives au service de la
société d'information
les délais imposés par cette directive
on conduit l'Assemblée nationale à
supprimer le délai de 3 mois pour la
mise en oeuvre du dispositif du texte
examiné aujourd'hui que nous avions
introduit à l'initiative de notre
collègue Jacques Legendre et ainsi
maintenir le texte dans la navette en
attendant la vie de la Commission
européenne comme les votait notre
rapporteur la Commission européenne a
émis des réserves sur le opportunité de
ce texte estime notamment que nos
autorités françaises ne lui ont pas
fourni suffisamment d'éléments pour
juger de la proportionnalité du
dispositif si les autorités européennes
semblent prêtes à se laisser convaincre
par le dispositif de la proposition de
loi s'est acceptation ne pourrait se
faire qu'au prix d'une Renault station
préalable de la France à la mesure
consistant à interdire la gratuité des
frais de port à défaut la France se
retrouverait sous la menace d'un
contentieux et partant d'une
condamnation nous saluons la
détermination de notre apporteur de ne
pas succomber à ce chantage en nous
proposant lors de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication du Sénat d'adopter cette
proposition de loi dans merci en
transmise par l'Assemblée nationale sans
modification notre commission à
unanimement soutenue cette proposition
en effet mes collègues du groupe
socialiste moi-même est Simon que nous
ne pouvons plus accepter de tels
injonctions de l'Europe si elle ne nous
protège pas par ailleurs elle ne peut
pas nous interdire de défendre nos
librairies et affirmer le rien pouvoir
contre le dumping social auquel se livre
les grands groupes si la concurrence
déloyale était empêchée par un minimum
de règles européennes nous pourrions
nous montrer plus conciliant mais tel
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui la prise de
conscience progresse y compris par nos
voisins allemands ou les positions ont
évolué sur la question de la gouvernance
et de la régulation d'Internet le groupe
socialiste votera donc ce texte qui
permettra de faire évoluer les choses en
Europe et nous offrira un peu de répit
pour accompagner les libraires dans une
réorganisation de leur filière et
répondre aux exigences de la
modernisation merci
merci monsieur le sénateur
la discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission je n'ai été saisie d'aucun
amendement je vais donc mettre au voile
l'article premier sol article de la
proposition de loi encore en discussion
le vote sur cet article vaudra votre sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi je
suis saisie d'une demande d'explication
de vote par notre collègue madame Goulet
oui Messi madame le Président Madame le
Ministre même le rapporteur mais le
président de la commission mes chers
collègues juste un petit mot
d'explication de vote sur ce texte
puisque en première instance je m'étais
abstenus
mais là je suis pas intervenu en
discussion générale je vais simplement
vous dire que je maintiens mon
abstention que je voudrais d'abord
féliciter le gouvernement de la rapidité
de la navette quand on sait combien de
textes restant carafe pardonnez-moi
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat que cette
semaine nous allons examiner un texte
sur
l'efficacité de la loi et la pertinence
de la loi je trouve que ce délai pour la
navette est absolument remarquable ce
qui prouve l'intérêt que nos deux
chambres portent à ce sujet et c'est
bien normal nous sommes dans la guerre
de l'obus du blindage
je l'avais déjà dit en première lecture
nous avons nous n'avons pas encore voté
ce texte et Amazon a déjà trouvé une
parade puisque il y a maintenant un
prime Amazon ou pour 49 euros par an
l'ensemble des frais de port sera
couvert ça veut dire que nous avons
d'ores et déjà la parade a eu un texte
qui n'est pas encore voté donc vous
voyez on est vraiment dans cette guerre
de l'obus et du blinda je maintiens que
le texte qui est pavé de bonnes
intentions et qui est important pour la
protection des librairies reste
néanmoins un peu cosmétique
on a beaucoup parlé de fiscalité
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus que pendant la
première lecture et je trouve que c'est
extrêmement important
mais si Amazon livre en 24 heures alors
que les libraires physiques sont eux
livrés des livres en 48 heures il faut
aussi se poser la question de savoir
comment
fonctionne le relais entre les éditeurs
et les librairies parce que il y a quand
même un problème qui consiste aussi à
régler et ce problème du livre ne
constitue pas une exception et ne doit
pas être limité à la plateforme Amazon
ou aux plateformes de vente en ligne et
au libraire il y a aussi les éditeurs il
y a d'autres acteurs dans le secteur qui
peuvent aussi être mis à contribution on
a évidemment parlé de la fiscalité on a
parlé de la loi sociale moi je voudrais
aussi attirer votre attention
sur les dispositions du traité
transatlantique qui sont actuellement en
discussion pour lesquelles les produits
culturels sont pour l'instant exclu mais
pour combien de temps la commission
économique de l'Assemblée parlementaire
du Conseil de l'Europe je suis
rapporteur général de la commission qui
s'occupe des relations transatlantiques
et je pense que le nivellement par le
bas des normes et de la régulation de ce
point de vue doivent être prises
extrêmement rapidement au sérieux
notamment par les moyens détournés qui
pourraient être utilisés dans le cadre
de ce traité transatlantique enfin j'en
aurai terminé Madame le Ministre en vous
disant que la question de l'évaluation
des aides que ce soit les aides à la
presse ou les aides au livre et au
librairie qui sont prévues je pense que
c'était doivent être absolument évaluées
on a extrêmement de difficultés dans
notre système législatif à mettre en
place des outils d'évaluation on l'a vu
très récemment dans le texte sur l'aide
au développement on le voit dans
d'autres sujets on a un certain nombre
d'habitudes on a un certain nombre de
dispositifs d'aide et on a très rarement
les dispositifs d'évaluation qui devrait
être leur corps et natif absolu de façon
à ce que le gouvernement et le Parlement
est subsidiairement le contribuable soit
tout à fait averti de l'efficacité des
subventions qui sont versées donc oui le
texte est important pour marquer
notre attachement au livre à la
politique du livre et au librairie
physique il est à mon sens totalement
insuffisant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'abstiendrai merci madame
la sénatrice je mets donc au voir
l'article premier
qui est pour
qui s'abstient qui est contre personne
la proposition de loi a tendance à
encadrer les conditions de la vente à
distance des livres et habilitant le
gouvernement à modifier par ordonnance
les dispositions du Code de la propriété
intellectuelle relative au contrat
d'édition et définitivement adoptée
et madame le rapporteur comme m'a
demandé la parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'aimerais
jouis de cette unanimité à une exception
près mais tous les groupes finalement
ont adopté cette proposition de loi je
m'en réjouis et je voudrais profiter de
ce moment parce que c'est je pense le
dernier texte de la commission de la
culture que nous aurons à examiner à
l'instar de ma collègue madame la
Présidente Gontier Morin pour saluer le
travail fait en commission vous savez
David insuline le sait bien les
conditions dans lesquelles je suis
arrivé à la Commission et puis on m'a
dit bon les choses étaient partagées et
on m'a dit ben écoute il reste le livre
et puis finalement j'ai découvert j'ai
découvert un secteur formidable auquel
maintenant je suis très attachée et j'ai
eu finalement alors que c'était pas du
tout attendu la possibilité de défendre
finalement plusieurs textes et ça
vraiment je m'en suis réjouis ça m'a
permis en plus du travail de président
de Pays Bas de pouvoir rester dans le
législatif et ça je m'en législatif et
m'en suis réjouit par ailleurs je
voudrais saluer madame la Présidente de
la Commission pour le travail fait pour
l'ambiance et puis
quelque chose quand même que voudrais
signaler c'est son esprit de résistance
qu'elle a su nous insuffler parce que
quand elle trouve un rapporteur qui
bloque qui résiste et bien elle
l'encourage et cet esprit de résistance
de la commission est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il a qui l'illustre et qu'il a
distingue particulièrement donc je
voulais le dire merci à vous madame la
Présidente
si mesdames les présidentes madame la
ministre
merci madame la Présidente d'abord pour
vous remercier de cette belle unanimité
sur tous les bancs en faveur d'un texte
qui est un texte très important qui est
un texte qui permet l'adaptation de du
droit d'auteur aujourd'hui à l'ère
numérique avec une des protections
supplémentaires pour les auteurs des
garanties supplémentaires pour les pour
les auteurs et donc voilà vraiment
l'adaptation du contrat d'édition était
quelque chose d'extrêmement attendu de
même que cette disposition sur
l'encadrement des frais de livraison des
frais de port pour la vente à distance
de livres dont on sait à quel point elle
est l'un des aspects elle n'est pas le
seul aspect bien sûr mais d'un vaste
plan en faveur de la librairie pour
lesquelles pour lequel nous sommes déjà
discuté le plan de 18 millions d'euros
qui associe des financements publics et
l'engagement aussi des éditeurs la
création du médiateur du livre la
fermentation des agents du ministère de
la Culture pour constater les
infractions à la loi sur le prix unique
tout ce que fait le Centre national du
livre enfin vraiment nous avons je crois
depuis deux ans construit bâti ensemble
une belle politique en faveur du livre
de la chaîne du livre et en particulier
en faveur délivrée ça s'inscrit dans la
défense de l'exception culturelle madame
la sénatrice et je tiens à vous dire que
dans le cas de discussion du traité
transatlantique auquel vous faisiez
allusion lors du dernier conseil des
ministres européens de la culture j'ai
interrogé moi-même le commissaire de
Groot et qui a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas
de discussion sur les sujets culturels à
partir du moment où le mandat de
négociation qui a été donné à la
commission est extrêmement claire et ce
mandat de négociation vous vous en
souvenez l'année dernière il a été
l'objet d'appro discussion et d'une
position très forte de la France qui
s'est opposé à ce que la culture
l'audiovisuel entre dans le cas du
mandat de négociation donc il n'y aura
pas de discussion sur les questions
culturel audiovisuel dans le cadre du
traité transatlantique c'est une grande
victoire de la France d'ailleurs qui a
fait prévaloir son point de vue c'était
grande victoire pour l'exception
culturelle je sais que madame la
Présidente de la Commission y est
extrêmement attaché d'ailleurs vous avez
été d'un grand soutien dans cette dans
ce combat l'an dernier et je tenais moi
aussi à vous rendre hommage cher
Marie-Christine nous nous connaissons
depuis bien longtemps bien avant d'être
l'une et l'autre dans cette hémicycle je
sais à quel point vous avez une force de
conviction je vis au corps ancré
d'ailleurs dans la terre riche féconde
humainement très chaleureuse du
Nord-Pas-de-Calais vous avez exercé des
de belles responsabilités et que vous
avez
cette alliance particulière comme le
disait Barry zakiari de d'une grande
force de conviction d'une capacité de
résistance mais toujours avec beaucoup
de douceur
et de tempérance c'est une qualité qui
n'est pas si fréquente en politique donc
je voulais moi aussi vous rendre hommage
merci merci Madame la Ministre merci
madame la Présidente de la Commission
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre l'examen
de la proposition de loi dite Amazon un
texte voté ici au Sénat en juin dernier